hola este es el vídeo de química
esencial número 37 y hablaremos de la
constante de velocidad pero antes de
este vídeo asegúrense de haber visto el
vídeo anterior en el que hablamos de la
ley de velocidad si no saben que es una
reacción de orden cero primero orden o
segundo orden
ahí lo podrán saber bueno en la ley de
velocidad m y n son más que exponentes
porque nos pueden decir cuál es el orden
de la reacción por ejemplo a participa
en una reacción de segundo orden o de
participa en una de orden cero bueno eso
nos lo dirán los exponentes y estas son
las concentraciones de los reactivos a
ive
pero recuerden que si tenemos una
reacción muy grande pueden poner todos
los reactivos y finalmente tenemos la
velocidad que nos dice qué tan rápido
ocurre la reacción y con eso nos queda
acá la constante de velocidad bueno es
importante que sepan que la constante de
velocidad en realidad no es tan
constante porque depende de algunas
cosas como la temperatura y la presencia
de un catalizador por eso hoy veremos
qué es la constante de velocidad y cómo
la podemos calcular miren la ley de
velocidad contiene a la constante de
velocidad acá y es acá es cuantificable
podríamos hacer algunos experimentos
recolectar los datos y así calcular el
valor de acá y la forma más fácil de
hacerlo en un examen de química es
calcular la velocidad de la reacción en
el tiempo y después usar eso para
calcular acá y bueno los valores de acá
pueden ser muchos porque en cada
reacción existen diferentes valores de
acá
porque hay tanta variación bueno porque
hay muchos cambios en una reacción
química entonces acá no es tan constante
porque depende de la temperatura y de la
presencia de un catalizador ahora
respecto al orden de una reacción
específicamente una reacción de primer
orden existe una relación entre la vida
media y acá porque las dos son
independientes de la concentración así
que se pueden calcular fácilmente una
vez que conocemos la velocidad podemos
calcular la vida media esta es la
relación y un excelente ejemplo de vida
media es la radioactividad ya verán
cuando se los enseñé entonces acá
puede variar muchísimo y esta es una
investigación que alguien hizo antes de
que existiera la química como es ahora
los investigadores publicaban todas las
constantes de velocidad que encontraban
en todos sus experimentos y miren si
observamos todos estos números son muy
diferentes y hay muchos valores
porque existen muchas reacciones además
no podemos simplemente observar una
reacción y saber cuál es su valor de acá
siempre tenemos que calcularla
experimentalmente en el laboratorio
ahora les decía que la constante de
velocidad en realidad no es tan
constante porque la temperatura afecta a
la constante de velocidad además de los
catalizadores un catalizador puede
acelerar una reacción esta es la imagen
de un convertidor catalítico de un coche
que acelera la reacción y nos ayuda a
deshacernos de algunas sustancias no
deseables que se producen en un motor de
combustión
entonces si analizamos la constante de
velocidad y también hablamos de una
reacción de primer orden aquí tenemos un
ejemplo de radioactividad
vamos a ver del lado izquierdo tenemos
menos moléculas de las que tenemos del
lado derecho pero veamos qué sucede en
una reacción de primer orden conforme la
reacción avanza podemos ver que la
mayoría de los reactivos
consumen muy rápido al inicio pero
después la velocidad en la que se
consumen disminuye vamos a verlo otra
vez si la mayoría de los reactivos se
consumen muy rápido al principio pero
después todo ocurre más lento y miren si
analizamos las moléculas que tenemos del
lado izquierdo vamos a ver al principio
tenemos 16 moléculas pero si avanzamos
un poco la reacción ahora tenemos 8 sólo
tenemos la mitad esa es la vida media y
si seguimos avanzando bajamos de 8 a 4 y
después de 4 a 2
pasamos de una vida media a otra y bueno
esta es una muestra muy pequeña pero si
quisiéramos contar todo esto tendríamos
que ser más específicos ok ahora veamos
cómo se ve el experimento cuando lo
grafica moss entonces que es la vida
media la vida media se simboliza como te
subíndice un medio y es el tiempo en el
que la mitad de los reactivos se consume
así es como se ve la gráfica de un
experimento de radioactividad este
rectángulo nos marca la mitad de los
reactivos que teníamos inicialmente y
que ahora se han consumido y abajo
podemos ver que eso ocurre en un año
ahora no siempre tiene que ser un año
podrían ser no sé cientos o miles de
años de vida media pero si observamos la
siguiente vida media ahora bajamos de 50
a 25 nuevamente se consume la mitad de
los reactivos que teníamos antes y si lo
analizamos de nuevo podemos ver que en
este caso la vida media es constante así
que en una reacción de primer orden
la vida media permanece constante por
eso la vida media y acá comparten eso
las dos no dependen de la concentración
no importa cuántos reactivos tengamos
acá y la vida media permanecerán
constantes y también podemos su cerca
para bueno claro una vez que la hayamos
calculado para calcular la vida media o
viceversa
existe una relación inversamente
proporcional entre las dos y ahora es
más fácil saber lo que ocurre en una
reacción de orden cero y de segundo
orden por ejemplo cuál es la vida media
en este caso bueno cómo se consume la
mitad de lo que sea que teníamos esta
sería la vida media en una reacción de
orden cero no sabemos cuánto tiempo es
pero podemos ver que después tenemos una
vida media más pequeña y después tenemos
una todavía más pequeña por lo tanto
podemos decir que en una reacción de
orden cero la vida media disminuye y si
analizamos una reacción de segundo orden
la primera vida media es muy corta
después tenemos una más larga y después
una más larga que la anterior entonces
miren simplemente observando la gráfica
y analizando la vida media podemos saber
si una reacción es de orden cero o
segundo orden y si la vida media es
igual con el tiempo sabremos que es una
reacción deprime
entonces aprendieron a relacionar la
vida media con la constante de velocidad
de una reacción de primer orden
recuerden las dos permanecen constantes
y podemos usar esta ecuación espero que
les sirva